our next guest is baroness helena
kennedy she's a highly esteemed human
rights lawyer who serves on a legal task
force which is helping to build those
cases in ukraine thank you very much for
being on the programme
today and can you just explain a bit
about the task force who is on it and
what it is you're trying to do
um
thank you sophie um but you're very
right in saying that these things take
so much time because it's so important
that the evidence is of
a very high level and that you are
pretty sure that you can pass some of
the thresholds that are necessary first
for prosecution and then for
hopefully convictions
um this task force was set up at the
behest of the prosecutor general who
wanted to have
some advice from lawyers beyond ukraine
feeling that she has of course
international
qualified lawyers there too
but basically to have that input and
discussion about what is most likely to
be successful um in the long term uh
it's very difficult as as your listeners
will know um the the united nations um
and decisions at united nations
inevitably and um because of that how it
was organized back in the uh in the 40s
after the second world war it it the
five nations basically have the voting
rights on anything substantial like
putting something before the
international court of justice and uh
and russia is one of those nations as is
china and uh and both of those nations
um often exercise their veto to prevent
actions being taken against um
as they would see it a sovereign nation
um because of their concerns that uh
that uh this could have consequences for
them in them too so uh we're not
expecting that russia is going to give
an agreement to any kind of inquiry or
a tribunal or court and so in those
circumstances one's presented with
serious problems how do you establish a
tribunal without the consent of the
parties who currently in international
law um
basically ratify whether there should be
a court hearing and um
and what is being looked at at the
moment are the alternatives to that the
international uh criminal court has
already um embarked upon an
investigation and that was voted for um
by a majority of the general counsel of
the united nations which can do that on
a majority and it was a substantial
majority um that investigation is going
on uh we are assisting in that um by uh
making sure that um evidence that comes
via us finds its way to the
international criminal court but that it
passes those thresholds which are about
being uh uh
likely to produce
a
a positive outcome because otherwise
you know you're really in difficulties
if you haven't got solid evidence this
is a case though where surprisingly
there is going to be
evidence fairly quickly and readily
available because of the quantity of
international journalists who are
present have gone into the country cnn
um sky news you've got a wonderful
reporter there from sky news um uh the
bbc's present many of the of the
international corporations media
corporations are actually filming
interviewing people and so you're
getting evidence which will be
immediately archived you've also got
people who themselves are taking
evidence because they're using their
iphones in order to film things that
they're seeing that's more difficult
because of course the allegation will be
made by russia that it's been interfered
with and that it's not um
being
properly processed you've got to make
sure that there isn't any contamination
or editing or anything that could have
in any way interfered with the probity
of the evidence
so there are some problems with that
there are people on the ground from
human rights watch from amnesty
international
from from the un itself uh who are
gathering evidence so evidence is being
gathered it's about human accumulating
that sifting it and unfortunately all of
that takes an incredible amount of time
the big question just now for um ukraine
is
they would like something positive they
would like russia to be put on the back
by being told categorically that there
is going to be a case brought in an
international forum of some kind
now the council of europe could for
example set up some sort of form as it
did for kosovo um a forum was set up a
tribunal for sierra leone which did not
involve um
it wasn't set up in the in the
traditional way it wasn't at the
international court of justice but
charles taylor was put on trial so we're
looking at all the other alternatives
that there are to how you could bring to
just
russia and uh senior figures okay um
it's interesting you were saying that
already there is this evidence of the
war crimes that have been committed in
ukraine you've seen them i've seen them
our viewers will have seen them uh
whenever they turn on their tv screens
or look at their phones
i guess my question is you know we talk
a lot about we stand back and we talk a
lot about you know the process of
gathering evidence
is there anything in particular that has
really shocked you to witness being
carried out
in ukraine on the program you know if i
talk about my own experience you know
some of what people have told me about
the treatment of women and girls that
the rapes
the way these civilians are being
treated and
is just absolutely devastating are there
any examples that you can give of what
you've seen
well
one of the things sophie um is that
a change has taken place
um internationally in the recognition
of
rape as a weapon of war
and and what what that means is not that
um
an instruction is given but from from
the top to go out there and rape uh
citizens uh women and girls or anybody
else but it's about um the the the sort
of tacit
uh permission that's given uh the ways
in which no one's brought to book or
called into line or disciplined and so
that gives an immunity to soldiers on
the ground they
know that that's this is permissible and
so what we've heard um and
and evidence has been gathered is that
serious uh offenses of of a grievous
kind have been committed against
citizens against women and girls um
that's that's a new thing in in
recognition and in investigating and
making sure that it's properly reported
now the other thing is um here we have a
situation of people who are in a bunker
in those steel in those tunnels in
underneath the steel factory in mario
paul
and uh and if russia does not enable
those people to get out and to have that
give them free passage into freedom then
um you're again talking about the
commission of a war crime if they end up
having to uh in their days in those
tunnels so um there's there are many
crimes we've we've witnessed them on our
news um
bombing uh residential areas um bombing
hospitals and orphanages
um the business of bombing the theater
where it was quite clear that citizens
uh civilians were in hiding to and chill
the na the word children was plastered
on the ground so that any any aerial
bombardment could see what they were
dealing with and yet they bombed that
place to smith
yeah when you're talking about the um
you know those images that we've seen
are there people sheltering
in those tunnels underneath mario pole
many many civilians lots of children
there we can see the images of them
certainly and we are out of time but
just quickly i was wondering if i could
get your take on how easy it would be to
prosecute vladimir putin himself for a
war crime
that that is always more difficult until
i mean until you have
victory
um by uh uh ukraine um and the aftermath
of that um uh it's very difficult um to
bring leaders to justice
it was possible you remember with
milosevic it has been possible with
other leaders and uh and of course after
the second world war nuremberg was
created and that was
you know a
a tribunal a court created by those who
had
been the victors in the in that war and
so um i
i think that we're looking carefully at
what the steps would have to be but um
we're a long way from that
okay thank you very much for being on
the program uh today uh helena kennedy a
really important voice there thank you